Congress now has a record number of
black lawmakers yeah this is
particularly awkward for the Tea Party
congressmen who keep thinking they're
all the same guy
I thought I saw you over there you know
what's really exciting news Consumer
Electronics Show has started up CES
that's where you people don't care about
our government anymore just new gadget
Wow you all ready for that one of the
new gadgets at the Consumer Electronics
Show is a belt that tells the person
wearing it when it's time to lose weight
another device at the CES is a pair of
jeans that tells you hey chunks try a
salad chunks that's how it's done two
chunks
another item unveiled at the Consumer
Electronics Show is a smart pacifier
with a GPS system I'm not kidding this
is real a a smart pacifier with a GPS
system that will help you find your baby
the company expects the pacifier to be a
huge hit with really shitty parents
[Applause]
well then I think I know where he is but
also to here's a GPS chip put it in the
baby's mouth yeah you know chill on the
GPS chip baby yeah you know how babies
are you never know where they are Dick
Cheney has gone on record saying he's a
big fan of Jeb Bush yeah I don't think
Jeb is excited because Cheney's exact
quote was if there's two things I love
it's waterboarding and Jeb Bush that's
my Cheney I do a lot of them a new study
has found that watching Fox News can
make you more conservative watching
MSNBC can make you more liberal yeah and
watching CNN can make you think that no
plane has ever safely reached its
[Music]
we're back with our hundred and
twentieth hour of coverage Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg has announced an
ambitious new personal plan to read
something new every two weeks he's gonna
read something new every two weeks yeah
first up on Zuckerberg reading list all
your private Facebook messages my little
hoodie yeah these are a real page-turner
yeah
scientists have created a pill that
tricks your body into thinking it's had
a full meal crazy yeah unfortunately the
pill is made of two pounds of mashed
potatoes 8,500 calories today Major
League Baseball's selected its newest
Hall of Fame members and the most votes
went to Randy Johnson yeah
later that day Randy Johnson was also
inducted into the porn star named Hall
of Fame
under status it is a good porn name it's
a very good one NASA scientists recently
spotted a hole on the sun's surface that
is four hundred times larger than the
earth crazy
despite the hole being that large no one
on the LA Lakers could put a ball
through
[Music]
thank you very much
half that applause was for the mine of
course
you